Airplanes are made of aluminum.
Aluminum foil is made of aluminum.Why don’t
planes crumple and why don’t my aluminum
foil airplanes work?
Hi flyers, Lissette here for DNews.
Flying scares the bejeezus out of some people
but it’s actually one of the safest ways
to travel.
That’s because along with the regular aircraft
inspections, strict regulations, and thousands
of hours of training pilots undergo, the aircrafts
themselves are made to withstand some pretty
incredible challenges.
The wings of the Boeing 787, for example,
are engineered to withstand one and a half
times the most extreme forces it would ever
meet in flight.
There are a lot of things that go into making
the wing that strong, like its design and
construction.
But the most important factor is the materials
used.
Materials are where everything starts and
they determine how easy a part is to machine
or weld, how strong it is, how flexible it
is, how it behaves at different temperatures,
how it stands up to corrosion, and how much
it weighs.
These are all factors aeronautical engineers
have to consider when they’re designing
different components of an aircraft.
And for decades, aluminum was the go-to material.
Forty years ago, aluminum could make up as
much as 70% of an aircraft.
Aluminum, though half as strong as titanium,
is lighter and, more importantly, much cheaper.
It gets stronger at colder temperature but
stays ductile, and has it’s own anti-corrosion
mechanism.
Today’s jets are only 20% pure aluminum,
but the metal is still present in abundance,
it’s just mixed with other metals to form
alloys.
Aluminum has so many alloys it’s hard to
keep track of all of them even though they’re
numbered.
The most common one used for airplanes is
7075, which uses a little zinc, magnesium,
and copper as well as trace amounts of manganese,
silicon, iron, titanium, and other metals.
The result is an alloy that’s as strong
as steel, but isn’t too difficult to shape,
drill, or weld.
Techniques and technology for machining metals
is improving - making other alloys available,
that were previously too hard to work with.
New alloys like titanium aluminide are replacing
older nickel based alloys that were twice
as heavy but just as heat resistant.
In some parts of the engine metals are being
replaced altogether by parts that use ceramics
reinforced with silicon-carbides.
The benefit of these lightweight parts is
that engines can operate at higher temperatures
and run more efficiently.
Reducing weight anywhere in the aircraft is
always a goal because it means the jet has
to use less power to move - saving fuel.
In the last decade, aircraft makers have gotten
even more clever with their materials in the
pursuit of lightness.
Composite materials were first used for light
structural or cabin components, but more recently,
they’ve taken over metal for some serious
structural parts too.
Composites are incredibly light and strong,
and can be molded into complex shapes.
This reduces the need for heavy fasteners
or joints, which are potential failure points.
Boeing’s 787 dreamliner was the first commercial
aircraft to use composites extensively.
It has kevlar honeycombs in the wings to make
them light, flexible, and strong.
The 787 also used carbon fiber to strengthen
the fuselage.
This saves weight, and as a bonus, the cabin
can be pressurized more than previous aircraft,
and composites can tolerate higher humidities
without corroding… making the ride more
comfortable.
Carbon fiber was also used in the engine housing
to trap sound and make aircraft quieter.
But engineers are never satisfied.
They’re are constantly coming up with new
alloys, designs, and construction techniques
to make aircrafter harder, better, faster,
stronger.
HRL laboratories, in a joint venture with
Boeing, recently developed the lightest metal
ever.
The metal is arranged in a microlattice structure
which means it’s about 99.99% air.
A light flexible material like this could
be used inside the cabin and save even more
weight on future aircraft.
So that’s the technology making modern aircraft
awesome.
But what about future spacecraft?
What do we need to develop before we can rule
the galaxy?
Julian talks about that here.
Now that you know what planes are made of,
does that make you more confident in flying,
or do you still get the shakes?